on n'a jamais trouvé un trésor pareil en
egypte toutankhamon n'a pas été enterré
dans une tombe royale
c'est ce qui l'a sauvé carter c'était un
type extraordinaire
c'est un très grand dessinateur
quelqu'un donc qui voit les choses
ils repèrent qu'il ya quelque chose qui
ne va pas déjà ils voient bien que on a
quand même des traces de toutankhamon
par tout effacer et lui est persuadé que
ça tombait dans la vallée d'hérault lui
même se met à chercher dans cette zone
et puis c'est parce que lord carnarvon
lui dit on va arrêter les fouilles que
là il tente le tout pour le tout et
qu'il cherche sous le village des
ouvriers et en fait c'était une
intuition géniale
ce jeune tout être atone en l'an 2 de
son règne devient tout anne ramon image
vivante d'amont est donc rétablie le
culte à monia on revient à une
organisation de la société antérieur
mais en réalité on garde beaucoup
d'éléments de la nouvelle société qui
avait été fondée par son père en fait on
peut dire que toutankhamon en quelque
sorte c'est le fondateur de la société
ram et side c'est à dire la société de
la deuxième moitié du nouvel empire 19e
20e dynastie le plus célèbre c'est
ramsès de toutankhamon a été enterré
dans une tombe qui n'étaient pas prévus
pour lui visiblement une tombe qui n'a
pas d'ailleurs une forme de tombes
royales qui est petit qui est en bas
dans la vallée des rois à un endroit on
n'attend pas une tombes royales
or web faisant et facilement
toutankhamon on oublie toutankhamon mais
en plus comme on a on a pas d'entrée qui
ressemble à une tombes royales
on oublie qu'elle tombe la tête était
plein s'étaient entassées jusqu'au
plafond
cinq mille trois cents objets découverts
dans une tombe
c'est la seule fois où on peut étudier
l'intégralité du mobilier funéraire d'un
roi du nouvel empire toutankhamon de
permettre comprendre ce qu'il ya dans
les autres tombes et puis 7 passes et
objets nous donne des informations à
tous les niveaux parce que sur leur mode
de vie
ce qu'ils mangent il n'y a pas que
l'aspect royal derrière ça il ya quand
même des objets intimes réel fin et puis
ça nous donne une hymne d'une idée de la
richesse
inimaginable de l'egypte à cette époque
il ya des objets absolument incroyable
le trône de toutankhamon le trône
d'enfants
en ivoire en ébène plaqué d'or et quand
on est devant on s'imagine un petit
enfant en train de scier j'ai fais pas
ça à chaque fois j'ai le coeur qui font
quoi or les gants qui sont très
touchants aussi on arrive à faire
quelque chose qu'on ne sait jamais
c'est à dire touché
l'être humain parce que quand on quand
on est face à nous nous avons des défis
et là quand on a des gants enfin on y
voyait on a le roy keane et c'est bon
quoi
c'est incroyable et en plus on a des
gants lin brodés c'est absolument
magnifique
c'est un travail 4k 3300 ans qui en a un
qui est particulièrement intéressant
c'est le ba qui était sur la poitrine du
roi et c'est un objet magnifique c'est
ce qui vous quittent quand vous mourrez
et si vous voulez revivre c'est ce qui
doit revenir et donc il est là c'est la
capacité donc de résurrection de
toutankhamon en plus c'est un objet
fondamentale en fait pour pour ce jeune
roi maure quoi les bijoux comme ça dans
la tombe de toutankhamon
il y en a des tonnes au sens propre on
en a pour des siècles d'études en fait
pour l'intérieur intérieur de découverte
pareil